Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Connors, again in this video we are going to go over what I would do with the person as we look at the different specific genes that are related to different tour markers and other factors that would influence or give us hints on what diet a person should be on.
So if we haven't done this with you yet make sure if you have your genetics back in your patient mind that we that we do this or if you're side up to do this this is what we're going to be looking at.
So this is your list of all your genes currently as we speak now 23 bees read about a little over 9,000 genes and there are certain ones that were more interested in than others so there's lots that we don't even know anything about yet.
So the M1 genes are the malec enzyme 1 genes and here's my sample patient and so just so you know on this genetic profile this picture here this is the gene itself you can see by cursor there so this is the gene these M1 genes this is a family of a bunch of different genes this gene right here this is the name of the gene you don't have to worry about any of that.
But this is what we're looking at is there a variant or a defect on that gene you will receive one allele from your mother one allele from your father and if you received no defective alleles from your parents there'll be a zero or a blank that means that gene is working as best as it can work.
Now there's other obviously other environmental factors that influence that gene's ability to function but at least from a genetic standpoint there's no defect on that gene.
If there's a one here that means you have a single allele defect or a heterozygous defect that means that gene isn't going to work quite as well we could say and if there's a two it's going to work even less quite as well.
That's not correct grammar but you know what I mean so we don't want to have two zone most of our genes it's going to affect the function of that gene so that's what we're looking at that's how we read this.
So this family of M1 genes what the malach enzyme one gene does is it affects your cells ability to use fatty acids to produce energy.
So then the cell would then more be apt to resort to glucose for the production of energy and function.
So in a cancer patient if a person has a lot of M1G defects they're going to be more prone to use glucose and lactic acid as a fuel source.
And in this video we're going over trying to discover what is some good hints at what possibly the cancer is being fueled through.
Is it being fueled through proteins through glutamate and methionine or is it being fueled mainly through glucose and lactic acid.
So this would be hit number one for our patient here if this was yours you have a lot of twos here.
Number of ones and some zeros and then you can look at how common is a double olial defect a two on this specific gene right here.
Only 2.7% of the population of this group we have about 21,000 people in this group but understand that's not a healthy cohort of people.
This is a group of people that are sick.
So we don't want to be only 2.7% of the sick people a 6.9% of the sick people have this too that makes it even more significant possibly that is an important pathway.
So already with this patient I'd say it's looking pretty good like we're going on a ketogenic diet because you don't use fatty acids very well in the cell for glucose, for excuse me energy production.
And you're going to be already more prone to fiery down glycolysis using glucose and lactic acid as a fuel source.
So the cancer is more than likely going to use glucose and lactic acid as a fuel source.
So we got to decrease the amount of glucose and lactic acid that our cells are exposed to.
Oh, it's a lot to chew on but that will help you understand just follow me with this.
This is how I look at a person's genetics to know which diet would be probably best for them.
The ASNS gene, this is another gene that has to do with glutamine and glutamine production.
So this person has a single allele defect, not a real common defect on this gene right here.
These ones are a little bit more common.
This would point to we really should decrease glutamine levels and glutamate levels.
So a little bit of conflict from this one to the last one.
So we're weighing this all out as we look at all the genes.
The HIF genes, this has to do with I have a video on HIF somewhere in our whole genetic pathway videos.
But HIF is how you will actually convert lactic acid, proveic acid into acetylgoids I may to get into the crem cycle.
And people with HIF defects are definitely going to be more prone to using lactic acid as a fuel source for their cancer.
So here's hit number two with these ones of this gene pathway that we got to go to a ketogenic diet.
So I'm pulling up these genes individually because they're not shown in our report because these are all fairly unique genes to when we look at cancer.
And last year I pulled up the person that didn't have any defects on.
Now this M-tore gene, they have quite a few defects on this.
The intervention for this would be EG-CG curcumin, possibly a little caffeine and resveratrol.
So that's what I might recommend for the person that we're going to op that.
A lot of people already have them on that product anyhow.
The TP53 is your P53 gene.
This is what the most researched cancer tumor suppressor genes there is.
Understand what tumor suppressor genes are.
Tumor suppressor genes are genes that are supposed to turn on if a cell goes into a rapid replication phase so that they suppress the tumor.
But these genes turn on, it kicks in a process to stimulate apoptosis.
So if I have a cell that starts to go into a rapid replication, aka cancer, a tumor suppressor pathway is supposed to kick on and cause apoptosis to kill that cell.
Well that's what we're looking at.
So P53 is one of the most researched tumor suppressor genes and there are no defects really to speak of in this person.
So P53 is more for colon cancer, which this person didn't have.
The pick genes, this person has a few defects in the pick genes.
Curcumin would be the intervention on that as well.
And the PET gene, which is a very highly research gene currently, they have a few defects on this.
So I would definitely put this person on it, increased amount of curcumin given their defects that they have.
The Keras pathways are very important pathways.
This person just has a few defects in this.
This would push towards a more ketogenic like diet.
So so far I would put this person on a more ketogenic like diet.
So remember there's three diets, the mixed diet is what all of our patients go on to begin with.
Then if you don't know what your genes are and you have cancer or you are watching this video and you have no idea what the genes are, you should go on our mixed diet, catch that video of the mixed diet.
Or a person is going to be on a more ketogenic diet which I would put this person on a more ketogenic diet.
Or a person is going to be on a more low protein diet, low glutamate and low methaniety.
Now this person I'm going to put on a fairly low glutamate diet and a ketogenic diet.
So this is how we tailor a diet to the patient based upon their genetics, not based upon sub dogma or sub book we read.
So we want to be as specific to possible.
So this person would go on a more ketogenic like diet and a low glutamine diet.
So it would be a very tailored diet.
So if you know anything about a ketogenic diet they're eating a lot more glutamine.
Well we're going to have decreased glutamine stores in this person too.
So it's going to be very specific for this person.
So that's how we look at just the cancer genes to look at diet.
And further videos will get more into each one of these genes and more details if you really want to nerd out on it.
But hope this was helpful. Dr. Cutters, thank you so much.
Bye-bye.